jamie dimon the chairman and ceo of
jpmorgan chase he recently released a
brand new annual shareholder letter in
it he talks about many of the risks that
are facing america its citizens and
investors within the u.s borders as part
of this letter we've got a number of
things that we think are important to
call out the first is that shaping the
next decade will essentially revolve
around three things a u.s economy
rebounding from the pandemic high
inflation that will usher in an era of
rising rates end russia's invasion of
ukraine and the resulting humanitarian
crisis that is now underway
if we take a look at jamie in his own
words we've got four quotes that i think
really say a lot about how he's thinking
about the world today the first quote is
that they present completely different
circumstances than what we've
experienced in the past their confluence
may dramatically increase the risks
ahead while it is possible and hopeful
that all of these events will have
peaceful resolutions we should prepare
for the potential negative outcomes
specifically talking about many of the
conflicts then speaking about russia and
ukraine he said that russian aggression
is having another dramatic and important
result it was coalescing the democratic
western world across europe and nato
countries to australia japan and korea
the outcome of these two issues will
transcend russia and likely will affect
geopolitics for decades potentially
leading to both a realignment of
alliances and a restructuring of global
trade he then went on to say that the
west comports itself and whether the
west can maintain its unity will likely
determine the future global order and
shape america and its allies important
relationship with china
then jaime discussed the federal reserve
in which he said the federal reserve and
the government did the right thing when
taking bold dramatic actions following
the misfortune unleashed by the pandemic
in hindsight it worked but also in
hindsight the medicine fiscal spending
in qe was probably too much and lasted
too long
and then lastly he went on to talk about
the fed should do and seems to have done
is to exempt themselves give themselves
ultimate flexibility from the pattern of
raising rates by only 25 basis points
and doing so on a regular schedule and
while they may announce how they intend
to reduce the fed balance sheet they
should be free to change this plan on a
moment's notice in order to deal with
actual events in the economy and the
markets a fed that reacts strongly to
data and events in real time will
ultimately create more confidence in any
case rates will need to go up
substantially now regardless of whether
you agree or disagree any time that the
major leader of a bank in the united
states puts out a shareholder letter i
run to read it why it simply gives you
insight into how they're thinking about
the world how they see markets
developing where they see risk and
opportunity jp morgan is one of the
largest banks in the world jamie dimon
is an incredibly intelligent individual
who's got a lot of information he talks
to a lot of different people when you
have somebody like that putting their
thoughts out there on the record it's
probably something that you want to go
ahead and take the time to read now it's
going to be interesting to see how this
all plays out in the coming years hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time